Estes Robert Scott he is senior
international economist for the Economic
Policy Institute first of all what is
the Economic Policy Institute we're a
nonprofit nonpartisan think tank here in
Washington DC we are concerned with the
way economics affects working people in
the US and around throughout the world
we've asked you to come and talk a
little bit about this whole issue of the
foreign United States debt and foreign
held debt there's been many articles
about this there's also been
hand-wringing about this there's also
people who say this is not a big deal
first of all step back and tell us
what's happened well the US has been
running a trade deficit we are
essentially spending more than we're
earning every year it's just like a
consumer who's spending exceeds their
income we're running up a curtain
nationally we're bringing up credit the
equivalent of credit card debt only the
balance is now up to about 2.7 trillion
dollars how did it get out of whack well
because we had been spending more than
we're earning since about the mid-1980s
and it's been particularly bad since the
middle of nineteen-year the 1990s
beginning around 1995 and it's a
complicated problem we're spending more
than we're earning in part because our
currency the dollar has become
overvalued that makes import cheap in
poor shape people say I can get cheap
shirts cheap clothes cheap furniture and
I'll buy more and it also makes its
credit cheap and so consumers can borrow
easily to make those purchases so the
system is encouraging people to engage
in a kind of consumption
I sort of like banks offering you you
know unlimited access to two credit
cards that low interest zero interest
loss later loans but ultimately you have
to pay those bills and that's the that's
the concern we are beginning to have to
pay those bills now the continuing
analogy the consumer is constantly being
bombarded by wanting by companies
wanting to give them the credit is
that's what is that happening to the
United States or did it happen over the
years in effect it has
and in large part over the last four or
five years it's actually been countries
not companies particularly countries
like China and Japan other countries in
Asia that had been loaning us hundreds
of billions of dollars paying happy to
do it and happy to do it paying for
those large deficits willingly and the
reason they did it was because they
wanted to export goods to the US they
were dependent on shipping as their
exports to soak up excess labor so it's
a what some have called a codependency
relationship we are dependent on them
for cheap credit and they are dependent
on us for exports and the jobs can be
generated that way we have some
statistics to show exactly kind of what
those numbers look are looking like now
with Japan being at the top explain
these numbers right right now foreign
countries hold about two point two four
trillion dollars as US securities now
the countries you see above Japan is a
large holder because their central bank
has part large quantities of dollars
likewise China their central bank has
also bought about a half a trillion
dollars here I think that number may be
somewhat low on the other hand some of
these other countries of Britain
Luxembourg and the Grand Cayman Islands
those are those are centers for private
brokers and their purchasing bonds on
behalf of others its asserted for
example that the Chinese are buying
large quantities of bonds through
private brokers and so they're in that
way disguising some of the dollar
purchases so what are the dangers for
the United States the principal danger
is that over the long term as we keep
borrowing we're going to have to pay to
pay more and more in interest to the
rest of the world already interest
payments in thing in the first quarter
of 2006 were over 110 billion dollars
that's more than we spent on health
education welfare
of non discretion and offense
non-discretionary spending so it's a
it's a huge burden on the economy and
what's the argument for people who said
this isn't really all that bad
well the concern is of course that we're
going to have less to spend at home in
the future
than we do now also we're vulnerable
right now interest rates are relatively
low at about 5% on government debt we
all remember when they went up to a 10
and 12 percent on debt so those payments
could go up they could double overnight
one of the questions that comes in to
this show specifically I have heard as
what happens if a country wants to call
in the debt right can they do that
nope no country is ever likely to call
in that debt to demand payment China is
too dependent again on its exports the
u.s. likewise Japan that's an empty
threat the real threat is that consumers
and investors in a private markets are
going to realize that this this house of
cards can't be sustained that we can't
keep borrowing and borrowing forever and
and the way to end that problem is for
the dollar to lose value we have two
ways to do that we can engineer a
gradual decline as as James Baker Reagan
President Reagan's Treasury secretary
did in the 1980s he got to go to the g5
and it gradually brought the dollar down
that made us goods more competitive and
it shrank the trade deficit we had at
that time otherwise we let markets do it
and in that case we're likely to have a
we could we could well have a financial
collapse as Mexico did in in 1994 and
many of the Asian countries did in 97-98
and that could be very costly push us
into a deep recession Robert Scott again
senior international economist for the
Economic Policy Institute previously he
has taught at the University of Maryland
at College Park he also has represented
in US industries as an expert witness on
economic effects of imports in several
cases before the US International Trade
Commission concerning unfair trade
complaints as his PhD from the
University of California at Berkeley and
his Bosch
degree in engineering from Washington
University in st. Louis let's take some
phone calls for you first stop
Manchester Tennessee hello good morning
y'all morning good morning happy happy
fourth of July it's a beautiful day here
I hope it is there absolutely not I'm
not an economist I'm just an everyday
citizen but let me ask you a couple of
things that appear to me and you tell me
if I'm on the right track okay in a
deficit economy which is what we're
running any time uShip revenue as per a
tax cut let's say for example the estate
tax changing the state tax any time you
do that do you not just shift that debt
from this generation on down to the next
generation regardless of whether that
debts ever paid off because apparently
nobody seems concerned about ever paying
those debts off but just shifting the
interest payments down that that would
be my first question my second question
is another thing we're not discussing as
far as I know back during the Gore Bush
debates Gore made a statement about the
lockbox of the Social Security surplus
really he was really Riddick you for
that and I really am reserves I think
that of the candidate Bush also said
that but he was in favor of of not
rating that surplus as far as I know we
still ate that surplus every month so
and then though that money is poor tea
with this bottomless hole of a spending
budget that we have Thank You Tennessee
thank you very much
good questions the interest on the
national debt and borrowing from the
next generation I think are serious
questions
we're running huge deficits in this
country in excess of half a trillion
dollars a year and I think the one of
the problems were countering now is that
whereas in the past we used to simply
borrow from ourselves we would sell the
Treasury bills to the Treasury and
they'd use Social Security funds to pay
for them and so we are essentially just
paying interest to ourselves now we're
sending those to Treasury bills to Asia
and we're having to pay the interest to
investors in Asia so that's reducing our
income in future the other
concern I have is that these large
deficits are limiting our ability to
engage in other kinds of government
programs like investment in research and
development the government's broke we
can't afford to make the kinds of
investments we do now and in needed
infrastructure and other investments in
our economy so I think that's a real
concern Maplewood New Jersey yes good
morning happy 4th of July
thank you I'm wondering how we can
compare this national problem to the
problem that our governor corzine is
facing and how can we look at the big
picture so to speak and and swing the
economic pendulum to more favorable
thing without spending our grandkids
inheritance so caller just so people for
people who may not know you're having a
special session there today right that's
correct governor Corzine is up against
that I'm trying to compare how it made
you know how it compares to when
governor Florio was a governor so you
know the Democrats don't seem to have
luck in New Jersey as governor so I'm
just trying to figure out what we can do
to help the situation without you know
paying paying taxes that are well beyond
our means it's just got well in this
case situation in terms of our
international problems if we can
engineer a gradual improvement in the
dollar that is a devaluation or
depreciation in the dollar that will
make our goods competitive it will
create demand for products made here in
the US it will create good jobs for
people making good incomes in
manufacturing and related industries
that will generate increasing inflows of
taxes to the government so the economy
overall will benefit as we shrink this
unsustainable trade deficit now I'm not
sure how we make the link to your
situation in New Jersey but of course I
wants to raise taxes right is that there
is there's no link there well there is
some link there are those who argue that
there is a what we call twin deficits we
haven't big government budget deficits
and we have to borrow from abroad to
finance them there there is some truth
to that if if we if we can raise some
revenues
to bring down the budget deficit it will
reduce the need to borrow from abroad so
there is a connection there is it
keedysville Marilyn go ahead
uh don't you think it's about time that
we address the sacred cow land that is
military spending in this country no
less liberals and Dwight Eisenhower
warned against the military industrial
complex nearly 50 years ago and they're
bankrupting us this country spends more
on military issues in the hardware and
personnel than all the other countries
of the world combined we spend more than
20 times as much as China and Russia
combined the founding fathers would be
appalled at the size of our standing
army because their position was the only
reason to have a standing army was if
you were being innovated this country
has been invaded only twice in US
history in 1812 and when the Japanese
took a to Island in World War two I mean
I think it's time that people start
realizing that it's not about the flag
it's about greed thanks Marilyn if we
were to cut back extensively on our
military spending would it make any
difference in the kinds of debt that we
were talking about there the numbers of
Japan at one point nine trillion it
would depend on what we did with the
money right now the US has low levels
investment in R&D if you take out the
military investment which the caller
would suggest doesn't generate much
wealth for the economy actual levels of
R&D put us in the bottom half of the
most of our countries we're far behind
Japan and other countries like that so
we're essentially losing our edge
technologically that's going to make us
a poorer country so if we can invest
more in domestic R&D we can we can grow
faster in the future new york city hi
yes good morning Robert my I taught at
the b-school I my first two years of
teaching George Bush jr. was my student
in accounting I'm supposedly an expert
in present value accounting who wrote
the cases let me give you some opps of
nations internationally from the
Japanese sides as I sit on boards in
China Japan worldwide and then I teach
the ANP course at W school in Japan
you've got three trillion dollars of ust
bills in corporate pension accounts
that's what doesn't show up so Sony
Hitoshi the pension accounts of control
I guess as you know not by the banks by
the insurance companies now I did have a
meeting in China on their financial
situation along the Financial Times and
the leading accounting firms listed bed
debt at a trillion I say it's about two
trillion so I'll give you a formula that
that I've worked out over the last
thirty years in teaching the president's
class like whatever the price of oil is
you multiply the first number by one and
a half and that's your inflation rate so
if you see $40 oil you're probably six
or seven percent inflation what may be
great for Clinton was he let out the
strategic oil reserves and ran oil down
to $15 a barrel what Bush is doing and
he knows and I guess I know is he's
bought over a billion barrels of US oil
using taxpayers money for the strategic
oil reserves it just is he doesn't have
enough storage space what'd you do to
resolve the problems he Clinton never
took a business course but he was a
Rhodes Scholar he's a very very smart
guy what he did was as soon as oil hit
36 dollars a barrel he let out 20% of
the US strategic oil reserves so also
I'll give you a dollar 50 Cent's
castling you take the 1 billion barrels
of oil is that a worthless
I mean I'm originally Canadian and we've
got if you need oil come to Canada right
we've got plenty what you do is you
write this formula down you take there's
a TV oil reserves
the extra billion barrels you take 500
million barrels of a while sell it at
market to the airlines and to the
utilities and people on Social Security
but I'll finish with this last statement
a person on Social Security earns $1,000
a month right right they now know the
person 68 with a wife has a car they
spend $50 a week more for gasoline
that's $200 a month you've got 20
percent inflation you wear the utility
bills an extra hundred dollars a month
it's 30 percent inflation so you want to
solve the problem on the gasoline you
take go into Congress you order the oil
reserves sold they're worthless
thanks mister Thank You mr. Scott well I
think the cost of oil is a major concern
and that's a going to be a problem if we
are going to have the kind of dollar
devaluation that's needed that may well
push up the cost of oil and I think that
it's going to be costly for American
consumers especially those on on fixed
incomes I think it's going to increase
the incentive for the u.s. to make
investments that we need in in renewable
energy and alternative energy sources
and alternative ways to transport
ourselves in order to reduce our
vulnerability to those a high imported
oil prices that the caller is talking
about next is Raleigh North Carolina
something you could address the theory
that with the current alignment of India
and China they could leverage the debt
that they have on us to uh basically
take over Taiwan without a shot just
like the threat of cashing in their
paper and thank you color I think this
notion that China in any India have
leverage over us with their holdings of
our Treasury bills is a is really a I
think it's a it's a it's a phantom
problem these countries are never going
to sell those Treasury bills that would
sort of be cutting off their noses too
you know despite their face they it
would destroy their ability to export
goods as the u.s. because it would
cause the dollar to collapse so it would
it would decimate their economy so
they're not they're simply not going to
sell those dollars in large quantities
the big risk the dollar is not from
China or India the biggest risk is that
domestic investors are going to realize
the dollars going to fall this is what
happened in Mexico was the domestic
investors who led the problem they
realized that the peso had to fall they
moved out of the pesos and into dollars
and then that became a self-fulfilling
prophecy and that's the concern we have
here in the US and when did that happen
that happened in 1993 in 1994 and how
long did it take before the problem
started it was about two months and how
long did it take for them to recover
from it it's taken them about six years
what Barry Heights New Jersey hello
honey you be on c-span I wanted to ask
you what do you feel or what what
percentage of the trade deficit or do
you know what percentage of trade trade
deficit as a result of the higher oil
prices obviously we're spending money
out of the country to buy oil that's
right we're spending about 300 billion a
year right now on oil and I would say
that at least half of that is due the
higher oil prices so and and our overall
trade deficit is about 750 billion
dollars here right now so oil is almost
half of the problem
Deerfield Illinois uh-oh I want to make
just one or two comments one of which is
the government's like a lot of people in
this country are as acid rich and
cashflow poor and I wonder why they
don't decide to make an accrual basis
balance sheet and just see how much we
really have in assets and one other
thing the government owns all sorts of
land out west and I understand that it's
being rented based on some laws that
were passed when US Grant was president
and his dirt is dirt cheap and they
never look into that and the government
really looked auto look at all his
assets and see what could be turned into
a cash flow Robert Scott well I think
that acid based accounting is an
interesting idea one of my colleagues
max wiki has also suggested that we also
need to develop both a spending and a
capital budget in the
federal government to draw attention to
the fact that we are not investing
enough in key infrastructure and
highways in school and healthcare and
R&D so I think different ways of looking
at the federal budget would be
appropriate his point about land well I
think that there are some public
resource issues there at stake if if we
sell off the land and the forest to
private investors it may be over farmed
and over harvested and I think that may
be damaging during environment so there
is a Public Interest concern in Corpus
Christi Texas all right mr. Scott happy
fourth of July
thank you I I have a question for you
sir I am a pharmacy student and I am
kind of worried about my future um after
I achieve my farm deep I am expected to
make in between a hundred and 150
thousand dollars a year depending on
what I decide to specialize in and as
I've kind of wonder if if it's even
worth it I mean what my my financial
future seems to be in jeopardy
because I do have a basic understanding
and say Keynesian economics but I I
really wonder if we're just not selling
especially on the pharmaceutical side
especially to Britain in Germany I what
are we going to do to rebuild our
economy hey what do we need to do as
citizens Scott well I think what we
really need to do is two things I think
we need to gradually bring about a
reduction in the value of our dollar
that will make the u.s. much more
competitive on world markets as a
producer of goods and services and and
the pharmaceuticals the industries that
you're concerned about and I think we
need to begin making investments at the
national level
to increase our ability to produce these
Goods we've let our manufacturing sector
decay over the last 10 or 15 years we've
lost our edge we've fallen behind other
countries it's going to take not just a
devaluation but it's going to take a
program to rebuild us a competitiveness
if we're going to be able to reverse
this trade deficit and recapture some of
these markets that we lost and who
oversees that I mean he's he's saying
what do I do whatsoever sees right who
oversees that well it would make two
points there I think that the Treasury
secretary needs to take the lead in
bringing the dollar down gradually
working with other countries in the g7
and the Chinese and Indians and I think
that in terms of your colors your
callers concerns personally one of the
things that many workers are worried
about is that they're going to be forced
to compete with workers in other
countries now it's gone much beyond the
manufacturing sector to programmers to
radiologists many workers are worried
and I think we do have reasons for
concern and estimates have been that as
much as 50 million workers in the future
will have to be could could potentially
face foreign competition and that will
put downward pressure on their wages the
services that won't be in such
competition of those that we call rooted
that are tied to serving customers here
on a face-to-face basis in in the u.s.
seem to me that pharmacy would be a
classic example of a rooted job so I
think that the caller has less to worry
about the many others and do members of
Congress have any leverage over this
kind of policy oh absolutely
the last time that we had a dollar
crisis in 1980s Congress was again
threatening to impose tariffs on the
Japanese which who were doing most of
the dollar distortion at that point and
that puts external pressure on the
government external pressure on the
Japanese in that case to bring them to
the table and it gets them degraded to
to in that case bring the dollar down
versus the Japanese yen and it works
next call for robert scott is from
indiana hammond indiana
hello you're on the air sir please go
ahead uh yes the question I have is this
I am unaware of any real economic
recovery for myself and my neighbors
here we all are working four and five
jobs per household where it used to be -
so the job numbers are bogus our costs
are going up rather than down and to
hear people from both sides of the fence
cast idli touting an economic recovery
when the majority of working Americans
are struggling working hard and not
making ends meet up with with five jobs
in my household right now amongst three
people we're making twenty thousand
dollars a year less than we did in 2000
this is a downward trend on wages that
the Democrats and the Republicans are
denying and I'd like to hear your
comments on what real working Americans
are feeling because I I see no recovery
and I'd like to see one I grew up in
Indiana and I'm very familiar with
problems back in that part of the
country and you're really living in the
core of the may of the industrial part
of the country and that sector of the
economy has really been most hard-hit by
our trade problems we've lost lost about
3 million jobs in manufacturing just
since 2000 and we have not gotten them
back and those those were gotten jobs -
paid good wages and had full benefits
now many people such as yourselves are
having to take jobs and industries like
retail trade where there are much lower
wages and often no benefits and as you
say having to take two and three jobs on
to replace the wages they used to get
from one job as a whole in the economy
wages have been stagnant since the
beginning of this recovery most of the
benefits have gone to - profits this is
the first time this has happened and in
at least 25 or 30 years in this country
so something has changed in a balance of
our economy and it's working against
working people Columbia Missouri hello
hi yes I was wondering where this
subject is always brought up
nothing has ever said about the United
States have loans to other country to
balance the three trillion dollar debt
or do we not have any loans out yes good
question caller we have investments in
foreign countries us firms have
investments of about three or four
trillion dollars in direct investments
that's where they own a significant
share of businesses in another country
and Americans also own billions of
dollars in stocks and bonds in foreign
countries overall I think we own about
ten or eleven trillion dollars in
foreign stocks and bonds and other
investments and foreigners own about
thirteen or fourteen trillion so what
I'm talking about is the balance the
difference between our assets and our
liabilities are the countries that are
holding most of our debt also the
countries that we have most of the
investment yes most of our investment is
takes place in the developed countries
in Western Europe and Japan and likewise
those those countries are supplying most
of the investment here Starkville
Mississippi good morning morning sir
could you explain the relationship among
the nation' that personal debt and
inflation that is what happens if
inflation skyrockets what is and what is
the probability of that happening my
second question is we are also the
largest consumer size Society in the
world if we stop consumption that is
financed by personal debt what country
is owned what replace us it's always
said that when the American market needs
the rest of the world catches a cold
Scott great questions thank you very
much
I think inflation is not likely to be a
problem inflation is controlled by the
Federal Reserve and Ben Bernanke the new
Federal Reserve Chairman has made it
abundantly clear that he has no
tolerance for inflation it's too bad for
the economy because he's probably going
to err on the side of being too vigilant
about inflation and it's going to push
up on unemployment in the economy
now the comparison between national debt
inflation and personal debt that's right
that's a tough comparison I think at a
personal level we are say as a country
we are really stretched out very thin
and I think at some point we're going to
reach our individual borrowing
capacities just as we as a nation are
going to borrow now you asked the
question about how we're going to grow
how the world's going to grow if the
u.s. is not there if we're not borrowing
all that money to make those purchases
we're going to have to make a very
delicate transition out of the situation
we are today where the u.s. is the buyer
of last resort into one where other
countries grow based on rising living
standards and rising consumption at home
the Chinese are going to have to allow
our wages to rise so that their workers
can actually purchase the goods that
they are producing and likewise Europe
is going to have to have higher growth
sounds like it's very difficult to do
but this is what happened in the 1980s
we actually had this kind of a twist the
dollar was allowed to depreciate other
countries simulated demand at home and
that's how we worked our way out of the
potential crisis without having a
collapse in the global economy so today
in the newspapers in the last couple
days we've been hearing about the
breakdown in the trade talks what impact
does that have in all of this I think it
has almost no impact right now the world
is so open there's very little incentive
for countries or companies to make big
sacrifices in order to engage in yet
further rounds of trade liberalization
let's take another call is from gladwyn
Michigan hi I am I was question on that
but we're gonna talk about giving away
all our social security and we're taking
care of medical payments and everything
how can we don't take it out of a
foreign aid to Mexico put some process
centers on there to catch them coming
over with TB and checking them out
before they even get into the country I
mean that wouldn't be that hard for them
to do that would help a lot of that and
as far as the Iraq war goes if we
our troops out of there they the Taliban
and all of their going to have that that
they'll have to take Kuwait in no time
and there goes saudi arabian we won't
handle all we have to get our choppin
axes out everybody it kind of be hurting
but right now I just don't I don't see
where we got a we got a do Social
Security for people that illegally over
here okay thanks thanks will changes in
programs like that have any kind of
impact on what you've been talking about
security yeah I think the Social
Security is a system that is basically
what we call pay-as-you-go the income
that's earned today from current age
workers is used to pay benefits to
retirees today and if we can manage to
to get through this transition that I
talked about we can rebuild
manufacturing that will generate good
jobs with good wages and incomes will
grow for workers in the US there will be
increased in flows or Social Security
payments as well and that will sustain
the Social Security system so the best
way thing we can do is is the lower the
dollar an engineer our way out of this
crisis we want to save Social Security
what about the issue of international
insecurity being in more the war in Iraq
the unrest in the Middle East how does
that impact the kind of the holding of
debt that we're talking about well two
points there first in terms of foreign
aid I think there's a there's a I think
people have a perception that we're
spending a lot more in foreign aid that
we actually are it's less than 1/2 a
percent of total national output whereas
we're spending about fifteen percent a
year on Social Security and Medicare so
it's a different scale of issues our
military commitments are a big issue the
military budget is well in excess of
four hundred billion dollars a year if
we could cut that in half and make use
those funds for investments in
rebuilding manufacturing and communities
we could grow wealthier but I'm not an
expert in foreign policy I can't make
those judgments that's what the folks
here in Washington are much better
prepared to do Robert Scott is
international senior international
economists for the Economic Policy
Institute
here in Washington DC thanks so much for
spending part of your 4th of July with
us thanks so much Randy that's great
well this afternoon beginning of 130
c-span will begin its coverage of the
liftoff of the space shuttle and we will
be the Speight the liftoff is still
scheduled for 2:38 we now understand
that there's about an 80% chance of
weather that is going to be favorable
for the launch
Jeremie Congress is gone for a week long
July 4th recess before leaving the
Senate tried to pass a constitutional
amendment on flag desecration sponsor
Orrin Hatch said he was counting on
undecided senators and we're hopeful
that they'll understand that this